hello and welcome is that the right
number yeah and welcome to the video to
this video and through our boo condo
something true condo so on
I'm all for limiting usernames to
whatever what do I have five eight
thirteen thirteen characters is fine
don't do more than that in fourteen
anyway so we've got a scotch four nights
maybe he has my book
you never know sometimes have to play
against my own my own repertoire choices
it's always fun it's not so much fun
actually
it's kind of a it's a funny situation
it's not fun to play against my lines so
I came it seems however that he's a
little bit surprised or need to remember
things most people are still surprised
by this okay that's not pre more
phenomenal
yeah this is um what you usually get in
this variation and black ISM of course
and completely fine it is just it's not
so easy to generate winning
opportunities in this position because
we have so many trades however what I
recognized is that in fact I think black
is in some way easier to play here
because white has this f3 move and this
is often a problem because it weakens
III a lot and my experience from some
games is that if you get the Knight to
d5 you have III C 3 you have those weak
spots that you can maybe use okay some
white ISM it seems trying to trade
everything it's unfortunately not so
easy to move the knight because of
Bishop to reform okay
anyway you can just play good moves or
try to play good moves and then see what
happens it is a little bit simpler for
Blacula the queen on c6 has actually a
pretty decent position it it allows
black to get the rooks onto defiance on
quite quite some quicker than White is
able to do it is fairly clear that this
whole line there with f3 and then taking
on c6 is leading to nothing it's just
difficult for black to get tension some
can maybe pre move Queen takes f6
it takes a long time is it really that
much of a problem
no so to check this and now I think
white should probably tickets okay if he
takes f6 I can I can take with the pawn
and I'm happily doing that the open edge
farm can be can be useful also because
of f3 because I mean you can make me
play h3 - ok ok you can maybe play h3 in
order to cover stuff on the edge file
but it's not so easy to do when you have
f3 played and you would see - was
hanging but I want to cover f6 first and
he has to take care yeah I would I would
have liked to play rook a to the a to
the a but hey salmon was unprotected
look f.2d one so what is this idea so
unfeigned if I take C tool what is he
doing then repeat 2 C 1 or D 2 c1
probably okay let's get this him and
introduce the odds tactical idea on edge
to c4 I think sorry 25 is one of his
ideas so I'm trying for a rope move - e
- yeah I'm not trading Queens that it's
not happening
note that rookie 5 can be a useful
tempore gain move okay so it's rookie to
move I think I can do that
okay Quincy to threatens rook takes h2
h3 and rook takes G true what's not
let's do this now
[Music]
does he have a defense Queen g4 maybe or
something
it looks pretty pretty problematic
already Queen g4 gauge 5 damn that was
yeah as I said it's not super easy down
yeah Bishop g4 is an interesting
recently discovered variation in my book
for white I'm recommending the move
Knight d2 as a way to just continue the
game let's say yeah the idea is that
after C takes h3 Bishop h5 watcing go c4
and this is I think roughly equal I
think white I can try to claim that this
is slightly weaker yeah and like
certainly has some claim that he has
good pieces like this that's what I
would play them it's think of roughly
equal position f3 is a more direct way
Bishop age 5 and I think D takes is 6
you can safely discard as being as being
not dangerous an interesting move was
Bishop to g5 that is maybe the most
interesting one the reason behind this
move is said after CTX d5 white can
actually capture yeah we have this this
sequence and this is not entirely clear
if black is is okay down my
recommendation is actually the somewhat
weird-looking computer more queen to d6
it I know it looks very strange but it
is it is quite quite a good idea and the
idea is that this blonde has a piece and
it's not quite clear what White's movies
he can take him
and then you have basically they're a
very similar position to the one before
but but here there's a pawn on d5 why
it's what cannot take on d5 and analyze
this a little bit further and I think
that it is okay for like yeah D takes
two six um we have this this position
and I think this is equal Bishop g6 is
securing or making sure that I'm getting
rid of the bishop pair is mentioned I
think in some way it is easier to play
form for black and we we saw some of
that I think the main issue actually was
that he took so long here for those
moves
yeah until I'm already significantly
better like the engine claims it's mean
it makes sense I have the H file ideas
this is a good central control with the
double pawn and I've got ten people so
King g7 oops
Oh gage eight I think makes sense yeah
I'm doing all the normal move so he can
take a seven I didn't she didn't dare to
do that i am i thought i'm either rupee
true or just queen take C form Queen
takes e4 seems to be better home yeah I
felt the sisters this is looking
dangerous but the engine claims that
white holds me okay for its compensation
yeah this listen out gets difficult to
play age three rookie - yeah I would
like to see if the final position is
winning yeah it is winning something
simple as this one a nice little mate
Jim Queen g4 I thought there wasn't I
didn't really hadn't made up my mind
what I would do then it's funny that a5
seems to be winning like I'm just
playing it can play any move and white
has no good reply yeah okay this is so
uh this is very okay
what happens if f 4 here look III even
what does that move to threaten f 5
winning the Queen Wow ouch ouch that
traps the Queen yeah
as you see you can win quickly with
black and this kind of variation at
least in a blitz game yeah one thing he
shouldn't have done is like spend a
minute or so on Bishop g6 that's just so
long okay guys thanks for watching